the best game to work on view right now
that that's doesn't sound like it
doesn't sound like it's a killer app
anyway no I mean look I I'm gonna break
one of your rules okay I'm gonna say the
game that I think is gonna be most
impactful is the one that you have
played right the oculus touch them the
oculus touch demo where you are engaging
with someone who is in an entirely
different physical space I think that is
the sort of experience that will make
people just unequivocally agree that VR
is special yeah and there and like I
mean you were doing it you were throwing
a ball to see who was in a different
room from you it was really strange if
for those who don't know it this is
essentially the you are you are a
wireframe head and fists and arms
because you've got the oculus touch
controllers as well yeah and you were
essentially standing against another
wireframe head and set of arms and
talking because it's all you've got
headsets as well and interacting and
throwing picking up items and throwing
them to the other person juggling and
playing all this stuff and what the
weirdest thing was that during this
whole demo we would keep like
high-fiving right cuz like I was like a
really simple version of touch that we
do with this other individual who I had
never actually met before and then after
the demo he walked into the room and the
two of us without even thinking about it
I was like wait we've actually never
even been in the same room together
saying but we've created this like
really crazy we communicated even though
we were never in the same room at all
yeah and so I think one of the big
challenges that oculus is facing right
now is it doesn't have those controllers
to enable the sort of experiences that
you're describing right VR can add not
VR in general rift and you know its
competitors can add things to games but
it really requires a lot more hardware
to make virtual reality possible the way
that people imagined it to be which is
that the total physical immersion vive
has the advantage right now because it's
shipping with those controllers yeah
they're available now oculus I think we
still have to wait a couple months are
those touch controllers and something
like job simulator for vive yeah you
know it's a cute little game but you are
really interacting with things like you
get the sense that like yeah I'm putting
my laptop in the toaster and hit and go
and I'm photocopying like
you know my tone oh yeah like whatever
like you actually are engaging with this
stuff in a little bit of an extra sort
of sort of special way yeah on top of
just the visual immersion that VR
supplies so I don't think that there is
a killer app for rift right now my
favorite is Chronos okay it brings back
the fixed camera system that made games
like resident evil have such great scene
composition yeah room to room so a lot
of opportunities for really great shots
and you are the the camera where you
look is where the camera looks around
the room and on top of that it's got its
got great gameplay it's like really fun
dungeon exploring with you know the
basic description is sort of Dark Souls
type combat and that game right now is
the one game that I want to go back and
keep playing but it's only available in
oculus so that's where I have to go play
it that's interesting because if this
isn't what people would consider or what
they would imagine necessarily when you
say oh this great oculus rift game
because essentially your head is just
taking the place of one of the camera
points in Resident Evil I guess you're
just looking right what is it about that
said that is it is there something
inherent about the control and what that
adds to the game or is it just a good
game that has this novel control or
novel viewpoint uh well the viewpoint I
wouldn't say is novel though I do think
I understand you're saying it's rare
these days it's a dying art which i
think is how I put it in one of our
features but what it really does is it
allows so even a scene like this right
here right where he was walking on that
shelf is a really small character if you
had free range of the camera you'd be
throwing it all over the place like yeah
trying to look at objects like scenes in
this game are composed in such a way to
evoke certain emotions and feelings out
of you and that is really important and
so when you mix that with a little bit
of added immersion that comes from the
headset it's a really great combination
even if it doesn't dominate like what I
think the game is it's an undeniable
part of it it's also like a big shift in
perspective a little bit of Chronos news
it was quite a while ago I was back in
Germany last year one of the the things
that I sort of didn't realize about
playing third person games because
there's another one as well what's the
that's the other third person the snow
edge of nowhere oh yeah yeah which is
yes which is another you know third
person game but what I didn't really
realize until I played these games was
that it's like having the television in
your face so like the amount of
the perspective actually kind of feels
more like first person in that you feel
very intimately connected to the
environment yes even though it's the
third person yes there is definitely
that sense of intimacy you know it's as
simple as like playing Lucky's tale
you're this Fox you're running around
the woods and one point you get away
from this really wide expansive
environment and you're walking through a
hollow tree trunk right and in that
moment I could feel the space around me
like closing in right like there was a
definite sense I don't have
claustrophobia but whatever I could
relate to that like that kind of feeling
and for yeah like a regular third person
game that we all know and love like VR
can add a little bit to it at least to
bring you into the moment at hand in the
game Resident Evil oculus remake the
present evil Teamsters are working in VR
really yeah they they start talking
about that I think at TGS last year all
right so I mean I would love that but
only if it's fixed camera I'm just the
problem yeah no I mean like one of the
reasons the original Resident Evil was
so good and one of the reasons the
remake is so so beloved is because this
technique has a lot of value even though
it was born from a place of technical
deficiency it actually it's pretty a
pretty sweet sometimes yeah they sort of
stumbled into AB accident while trying
to fix like a believability yeah yeah so
I would love does here isn't evil go
back to doing that especially I mean
sure VR otherwise cool last point on
this when are we get when is the vibe
going to be officially out of mana we
have a review for that so I believe it
starts shipping next week our review
should be April 5th right now we have
not the final consumer version close to
though I mean it's essentially an
analogue but we don't really say for
certainty we should be getting ours any
day so hopefully yeah no problems there
will at least have the hardware review
up on Tuesday cool and again with games
to follow how you feeling about each or
the other right now lot see what's your
preference after spending all that time
with the rift and having a decent amount
with the preview version of the 5
I mean cost of cost isn't even a factor
I mean I really appreciate how 5 has
just more options open so that if you
want to be in one of those experiences
where you can manipulate objects where
you can walk around your environment you
can do a little bit of that with rift I
think it's like a three by three foot
space right but with vibe you just have
so much more room to move and interact
things so right now my preferences vibe
cool alright I'll review next week thank
you so much Peter Brown let us know what
you think about the future of the
virtual reals in the comment box below
Mike my Hardy what do you think about
all this I'm adding you had much
experience using either of them yeah
so I went to an oculus rift recently the
day before GGC started okay then I went
all my demos a GC were all oculus or
five yeah most of yourself right yeah
and then PlayStation I did a couple at
PSX that if you PlayStation VR things
and I'm definitely sold I'm on board a
drift like I said was better in VR I
might go back and play a few more hours
I want up like Kronos at some point
definitely because I played about two
hours total of that and it really
between like it's Delta influences
almost like Dark Souls like combat kind
of and then you know a few other
mechanics P was telling me about and the
resin evil camera angles okay so
essentially you are sent back in time to
sort of save humanity and this portal
you go through you can throw nons god
yeah you can only have two place
tomorrow at one time per year okay when
you die you get sent back in time so the
theory is every time you die you gain a
year forever I hear you gain you become
more inherently proficient in magic okay
less inherently proficient with physical
attacks right so as you age you sort of
evolved as a character in more than just
physical appearance but then at the same
time that it kind of devalues that
mechanic a little bit because you also
gain perks for every decade you could
grow older so you can just like real
life just like real life
yeah you have AARP tax brackets yeah
sure yeah but yeah that's got a really
interesting death mechanic but anyway
yeah I wish that game was not just a VR
game at the moment because I think more
people really should play it right
Chronos I think that you could release
this game is not a VR game I think I
think honestly I think that there is a
chance it is coming out on PC and it's
not a hundred percent sure but I know
right now it's just on rift right
you